so um you know as I as I mentioned
earlier we're talking about best episode
selection here for Lee squares but we
can just as well do this for logistic
regression or for any other type of
model
um and in particular when we're talking
about other types of models we don't
usually talk about residual sum of
squares instead we talk about something
that's called the deviance which is
negative two times the log likelihood
and in the in the case of of
um least squares the deviance and the
residual sum of squares are equivalent
but for other model types the deviance
is really just a generalization of
residual sum of squares but here we're
going to talk about residual sum of
squares for Simplicity
so you know in that in that figure we
were looking at a couple slides ago with
the credit data we saw that there were
all of those gray dots and I mentioned
that there's actually two to the 10 gray
dots in that picture
and and the idea is that if I have a if
I have access to p predictors and I want
to consider every possible sub model
I'm actually looking at 2 to the p
subsets and that is an absolutely huge
number so just to put this in
perspective you know like 2 to the 10
that's like a thousand
so that's okay fitting a thousand models
if you've got a decent computer is no
problem
but 2 to the 40
is a really big number
and so the idea is that um
when when p is large we're really not
going to be able to do best subset
selection and 40 predictors isn't large
like I work I work on data where there's
easily tens or hundreds of thousands of
predictors and so Beth that sub
selection just does not scale for many
of the types of problems that people are
interested in today
I think the limit for most packages to
do subset selection is about 30 or 40.
and beyond that they just say I can't I
can't look at all the combinations right
protection also suffers from statistical
problems and the idea is like if if I'm
considering gosh what is this this is a
trillion models if I have 40 predictors
and I'm considering a trillion models
um I'm going to overfit the data I'm
just looking at so many models I'm going
to choose a model that looks really
really great on this data by chance but
it's not going to look great on an
independent test set that I didn't use
in in training the model and so I'm
going to have a problem with overfitting
and so for these two reasons
computational and statistical
best upset selection isn't really great
unless p is extremely small and in this
setting we can use stepwise methods
which sort of are the same idea as best
subset selection but they look at a more
restricted set of models so instead of
looking at two to the P models they look
at more like P Squared models and of
course 2p is much more than P Squared
for for any P of any reasonable size so
this point that the element is actually
pretty somewhat counterintuitive
especially people in computer science
might think it's always best to do the
the most exact computation you can if
you can do the optimization over all
models it's usually felt to be better
but Danielle said something that's
actually quite somewhat counterintuitive
that actually
to avoid fitting too hard it's good to
actually not look at all possible models
but only a subset of the models so for
its stepwise regression which we'll look
at is Step wise and fourth step wise in
particular
doesn't try to look at all possible
models despite the fact that in in in
cases when p is less than 40 so you can
look at all possible models it may not
be the best thing to do that so for step
wise on purpose
um looks only at a subset of the models
and that can actually be helpful yes I
mean best upset selection what would P
be if you're going to use it and what
would be your limit where if p is larger
than that number you wouldn't want to go
beyond that subset
uh I wouldn't want to use best subset
maybe not Beyond 10 or 20 say yeah I
don't think I would probably even use it
for 20 . I think I would use the subset
if I've got a handful of predictors and
if I've got 10 I wouldn't be using that
anymore most likely yeah so the point is
it's not always best to do a full search
even when you can do it because you pay
a price in variance
so so
nice methods forward and backward
stepwise and these are really pretty
similar
um but there's just one fundamental
difference which is whether you're
starting with a model with no predictors
or you're starting with a model with all
the predictors so in forward stepwise
selection we start with a model that
contains no predictors this is just a
model with only the intercept it's what
we were calling the the null model m0
earlier
and then we're going to add predictors
to the model one at a time until all of
the predictors are in the model
so this sounds like best subset
selection but there's actually a really
major difference which is that at each
step we're not looking at every single
possible model in the universe that
contains key predict K predictors we're
just looking at the models that contain
the K minus one predictors that we
already chose in the previous step plus
one more so at the Kate step we're
looking at a much much more restricted
set of models than than we are in in
best subset selection
in particular at each step we're just
going to choose the variable that gives
the biggest Improvement to the model we
just had a moment earlier
so the idea behind forward stepwise
selection is that once again we start
with this model m0 it's the null model
and it just contains an intercept so
you're just I'm going to predict the
mean for every observation
and then we're going to try to create a
model M1 and the model M1 is going to
just contain one more predictor than m0
so we're just going to take m0 and we're
going to look for the best predictor to
add that's going to lead to the smallest
RSS or the largest r squared
so that gives us M1
and now in order to get M2 we're going
to take M1
and we're going to consider adding every
predictor that we can one we're going to
consider adding all P minus 1 possible
predictors to M1 and we're going to see
which of those P minus 1 predictors
gives us the best model M2
and to get M3 we look at M2 we consider
adding all P minus two predictors that
aren't in M2 we choose the best one and
that gives us M3 and so on
so the really key thing here is that in
this step this is different from what we
were doing in in the best subset
selection case because here we're not
looking at every possible model
containing K predictors instead we're
just looking at every possible model
that contains one more predictor than M
K minus one where we're going to take
the model we just got and we're just
going to add one predictor to it to get
a slightly bigger model
so just like in best subset selection
we're going to get p plus one models
from m0 to MP
but the difference is that these models
are nested
so MP M1 contains the predictor in m0
plus one more M2 contains M1 plus one
more predictor M3 contains the
predictors in M2 plus one more and so on
these models are nested in a way that
wasn't the case for a best subset
selection
so after we get these P plus one models
we're going to choose among them and as
I mentioned earlier we can't use RSS or
r squared to choose among these P plus
one models because they all have
different sizes and in a few minutes
we'll talk about some approaches like
cross-validation and AIC and Bic to
choose among these P plus one models
so
we we've said that um
that forward stepwise selection has a
computational advantage over best subset
selection
and just to really reiterate why that's
true in best subset selection
we're considering two to the P models
which as we said is like a trillion when
P equals 40.
but in contrast in forward stepwise
selection
for m0 we're just considering one model
um and to get M1 we're considering
adding P different predictors so we're
considering P models
for M2 we're considering adding P minus
one additional predictors so that's P
minus one models and so on
and so actually when we do forward still
stepwise selection we're considering
around p-squared models
and so P Squared is much less than 2 to
the P so we're considering far fewer
predictors when we do forward step wise
and here's another picture to help see
what's going on and see if I can draw it
but if we think of the RSS picture
is because the function of model size
remember this is RSS and for best subset
remember it of course we said the career
keeps going down
it might flatten out
um
but for so this is for best subset
I saw that before
step Wise It's also going to have the
same shape but
um it's not going to go down it's going
to be it might be it's going to be above
that curvature so I'll start in the same
place because for one variable it's
going to pick the
the same best variable but it's going to
be typically above that curve I'm not
doing it very well
until the very end whoops that wasn't
these are meant to join at the end
so the point is that forward step wise
is not doing a search among all possible
models so for a given model size
it's going to have an RSS that might be
above typically will be above that for
Ford for best subset
right
so yeah I mean that relates to the fact
that um forward step wise isn't actually
guaranteed to find the best possible
model out of all two to the P models
that the best subsets the best subset
considers so like if you look at Rob's
picture
um right here the forward step wise and
best subset curves oops have the same
RSS because they each contain just the
null model and then over here these two
models are the same because forward step
wise and best subset are each
considering the model with all P
predictors so those are the same but in
between there's this Gap and the reason
for the Gap is because best subset
selection is going to find the best
model with let's say k predictors but
forward step wise might not and the
reason that it might not is because it
could be that the best model containing
K predictors is not a superset of the
best model contained in K minus 1
predictors
so we can actually see an example of
that if we look a little more carefully
at the credit data so um this table
shows the results that you get if you
fit if you look for m0 M1 M2
M3 and M4 on the credit data so this is
M1
M2 M3 and M4
and so if we do best subset selection
then M1 just contains rating
the rating variable and if we do forward
step wise M1 just contains the rating
variable so so far so good
if we look at M2 then best subsets M2
contains rating and income and same with
forward stepwise is M2
if we look at M3 best subset has rating
income student and same thing with Ford
stepwise rating income student but when
we get to M4 things suddenly change
because now in the context of a model
with four variables the best that we can
do is cards income student and limit
but that is not a model that forward
stepwise can give us because remember
forward step wise can only give us a
model that contains rating income
student and one other variable so
forward stepwise is going to give us
rating income student and it's going to
add in limit when we ask for the best
model with four variables and in
contrast best substet isn't going to
have rating it's instead going to have
cards and it's lost rating
and so this M4 the best subset gives us
is going to have a smaller residual sum
of squares
it's a different model than we would
have gotten with forward stepwise
um but you know just because best subset
has a better model on the training data
it doesn't mean that it's really going
to be a better model overall in the
context of test data which is what we
really care about well one more point
about that so you might wonder why this
happens well it only happens when the
correlation between the features right
it's pretty easy to show that if the
variables we had no correlation then uh
the the variables chosen by the two
methods would be exactly the same
because the correlation between the
features which is typically there you
can get a discrepancy between best
subset and forward stepwise